hey
let's go make a cooking video
hey everyone welcome today we're going
to be doing advanced pizza pops
first thing we need to stress that these
are pillsbury pizza pops
not pizza pockets made by the slatterns
over at mccain
now first thing we're going to do is
take the pizza pops out of their wrapper
and place them
on an already used plate you can use a
clean plate if that makes you more
comfortable
but just know that it's not the same
when you put the pops on the plate first
make sure that these
grill marks on the bottom of the pops
are facing up
since we want the final plating to be
right side up and we'll be flipping them
part way through the process
we're thinking ahead here once they're
ready the first thing to do is put them
into the microwave for 80 seconds
alright that's done take them out and
before you do anything else
first flip them over then put them back
in the microwave for 40 seconds
here they are we've got a little bit
spilling out where all the fillings have
burst out of the side
let's check out our color oh yeah look
at that
even cheesy saucy warm all the way
through
mmm so good that is a great pizza pop
so i like watching cooking entertainment
which isn't really a deep admission or
anything
it's an interest i share with millions
of other people
cooking shows are extremely mainstream
and in light of structural and cultural
changes at youtube over the last couple
years
they are increasingly becoming the face
of youtube
and that makes sense if we break down
the incentives that are at play
cooking shows have natural synergy with
a lot of brands and advertisers they are
generally family friendly and well
they're not apolitical they are rarely
openly partisan
being more involved in the inherent
politics of food than
daily legislative news they are also
increasingly being run by comparably
large
media organizations with a substantial
number of employees
which allows them to maintain a fairly
prolific production schedule
these factors combined make them
appealing to corporate youtube as the
face of the platform
because they're professional high
quality advertiser friendly strongly
personality driven
still a little bit scrappy and diy but
unlikely to draw negative attention to
the platform
like the bon appetit test kitchen crew
are
unlikely to pay a bunch of guys on
fiverr to hold up signs saying
death to jews or post a video of a dead
body they found in the woods
that's just not something i see
happening now
of course you can find exceptions to all
these generalities but
that's just as much a strength of the
genre the subject of food is one that
can be approached from a lot of
different angles
and find a foothold and again it's easy
to see why
food is one of the few truly universal
things
everyone needs to eat but it's also
highly localized highly cultural and yes
highly political what you eat says a lot
about where you're from
what you believe and how wealthy you are
marie antoinette almost certainly didn't
actually
say let them eat cake when told that the
peasants were out of bread
and not just because she spoke french
but the phrase
so often attributed to her has become a
shorthand
for the disconnect between the wealthy
and the working class
and it does this through the metaphor of
food food
is a universal need and yet we live in a
world where that need is met very
unevenly so while bread and cake are
inert
objects with no will of their own they
represent
so much more bannock in canada refers to
a style of fry bread that's associated
principally with indigenous culture
it's a simple recipe that's quick to
make tasty
is easily enhanced with mix-ins like
nuts and berries
and goes great with classic country jams
and jellies like
saskatoon berry on years when i attend
the calgary stampede i make sure to stop
by the bannick stand because it's a
great snack
for sitting in the july shade listening
to the bustle of the crowd
as you watch the ducks paddle around on
the bow river
with regional variation it is a nearly
universal dish among canada's indigenous
cultures
but that's kind of the hitch isn't it
it's universal from the high
arctic to the pacific coast over the
great plains through the canadian shield
to the maritimes on the east because its
ingredients
reflect the standard government rations
packages
that were available after tribes were
forced off their ranging lands
and into the reserve system in the late
1800s
this is what i mean when i say the
inherent politics of food
so of course cooking entertainment can't
avoid that
any show is going to inherit those
meanings and symbols
purely by virtue of the kinds of food
the show considers normal
what it considers exotic and what it
assumes
the viewer is familiar with or has
access to
even if a channel is trading on the
spectacle of creating something using
absurdly expensive ingredients for the
vicarious enjoyment of an audience
they could never afford them the channel
operators themselves
do need to be able to afford them you
can't for example demonstrate 30
different ways to cook kobe beef steak
without having access to 30 kobe beef
steaks
perfect if you're having i don't know
any kind of like glam party or like a
girls night at home
or for new year's these would be perfect
they are made gold with edible gold leaf
so these are a little bit expensive to
make because gold leaf
doesn't really come that cheap there is
also a persistent problem in food
entertainment where it intersects with
travel entertainment
and that is the exploitation of other
cultures
now this is a fine line and it's not as
simple as you know
folks making curry but rather think more
of creators trading in other cultures
specifically because those cultures will
appear exotic
and strange to viewers often framed as
the host
discovering a dish or destination this
is particularly pronounced where food
culture
transitions to wellness culture where
the perceived exotic
or exclusive nature of grains or fruits
is
leveraged to give the veneer of
authority to grandiose claims that they
are
super foods possessing special
properties if not
nine mystical powers the properties
contained in acai berries
have also been said to help prevent
certain health issues
like arthritis inflammation obesity
neurological diseases and allergies plus
they help to boost our energy
and improve our sleep i'm going to show
you how to make an activated charcoal
detoxifying lemonade
this is sacha inchi which is very high
in protein here is goji berries
here we have lucuma powder maca powder
here we have
moringa powder if you've ever been to
whole foods with me
then you know i'm the guy that's
obsessed with superfoods
i'm the weird dude that smells like
essential oils and has a cart full of
foods
that most people have never even heard
of so i've got i've gone the herbal
route i've got dr morris herbs
in my cupboard um 8 to 10 10
high carb low fat i've done high fat
i've done
whole food plant-based for years i've
done junk food vegan
i tried it all i drank my own urine for
two years almost every single day for
two years
do urine drinking diets count as cooking
videos
let me know in the comments so what is
the state of food entertainment on
youtube like let's say that you want to
get in on all that
what should you know about the biz
before you start
hey everyone welcome today we're going
to be doing the perfect
can of soda so first thing you want to
do is hook the tab with your middle
finger or
maybe your index finger then pull that
tab up to open the can
and that's pretty much it
ah well that is one great beverage
now you just need to protect it from the
cat come on kitty off the table
well first of all don't a cooking show
is a smaller scale version of opening a
restaurant
it's a bad idea because everyone thinks
they can do it
and of course like opening a restaurant
everyone already knows it's a bad idea
but everyone does it anyway also like a
restaurant there's a lot of competition
and it can be really
really hard to find a niche and audience
before you just
burn out because there are a lot of
hidden hurdles to overcome
a bit of personal backstory i actually
have
a ton of experience shooting food on
video
for a couple years i worked with a
mid-sized north american franchise
making
literally hundreds of internal training
videos for
food prep recipes plating instructions
the whole deal
coming out of that i dabbled with the
idea of making either a side show
or a new channel focusing on weird
mid-century party dishes
and tested the idea with two hastily
made proof of concept
videos why would you make that much
blue cheese flavored cream cheese
and then mold it into a snowman it
didn't go well
that mayo does not do it any favor no
why
one of the things you learn really fast
working with food is that well it's not
that hard to make it look you know at
least good and appetizing
it's also really really really easy to
make it look
awful to end up with a delicious sauce
that looks like greasy vomit and this is
because your kitchen
is probably a terrible place to make
videos it's
dark it's cluttered you've got dishes
piled up because you've been shooting
cooking videos for three days the light
is all on the wrong side of the room
from the stove
which is where you're working and the
stove itself is lit
by just a truly abominable
eight watt bulb that just makes
everything look
like just greasy and ugly every stray
bit of grime is going to make you feel
so gross the moment you're looking at it
on video your fridge is almost certainly
extremely loud and is the internet gonna
judge you
for the kettle that you just leave on
the stove
because you don't it doesn't fit in any
of your cabinets
the answer is yes also you're really
going to want a second pair of hands
because recording yourself is
challenging at the best of times
and somehow is just that little bit
worse
when you're trying to make something i i
just want to demonstrate how much i
needed to move
this microwave is just here as
a prop and i had to shove the couch
basically into the entryway
in order to get the camera into the
right position
in the living room adding to all that
the current quality threshold for
cooking videos on youtube is pretty high
even smaller channels are expected to
have the kind of production values that
come from having a dedicated recording
space with
lights audio equipment and background
the current aesthetic
biases towards crew that have access to
production kitchens or studio space
not just because that makes things look
good but because it just
makes the videos easier to make
and that's all before you even decide
where you're going to position yourself
on the three pillars of food
entertainment
informational value spectacle and
personality
now the state of youtube being what it
is you can do spectacle and value
without the personality and you can do
spectacle and personality without the
value and you can do all three
concurrent or consecutive but you can't
do value and personality without the
spectacle
spectacle is compulsory now spectacle
isn't a bad thing and for our definition
here it
encompasses a bunch of different kinds
of spectacle from dishes made with
absurdly expensive or difficult to
obtain
ingredients to excessively large or
complex constructions
to comically unusual methods or
ingredients to simply watching a master
of their craft
do something at an extremely high level
of competence
these are the gummy snacks known as
gushers
except we've constructed ours filled
with squid
ink also while this type of framing like
breaking all this down into the three
pillars of
whatever is really popular with the kind
of folks who have brand guru in their
twitter profiles and can be quite useful
in
identifying broad trends or
self-evaluating
this is not meant to be applied
religiously and it does tend to get a
lot hazier as you drill deeper into
specifics
like at what point does personality
itself
become spectacle but realistically i'm
just trapped
in this kitchen with all of these people
trying to make me fail
what i'm saying is that this is a useful
way of conceptualizing things
but don't go trying to like distribute
exact percentages
as though you're assigning skill points
in a video game to use bon appetit as an
example
while their most popular videos
absolutely utilize the spectacle of
a meal making a beef smoothie or claire
investing days of effort into producing
a single plate of gourmet tater
tots that is not the sum total of the
brand
bon appetit also swings to the extreme
opposite ends with videos like
how to butcher a pig being intensely
informational
and honestly pretty dry so here's a
breakdown of the shoulder
and now what i'm going to do is trim and
clean these cuts
in a way that you might see them in a
butcher shop this video in particular is
fascinating to me because while a
general audience can follow the subject
matter just fine
a lot of the video's actual language is
business advice for working butchers
bellies get turned into bacon bacon is a
great
value-added product for butchers
everybody loves bacon so it's definitely
within the butcher's best interest to
have as much bacon as possible
spectacle is the hook and no it's not
strictly necessary you can absolutely
create a cooking channel that trades
entirely in being strongly informative
driven by a big personality but
spectacle
sells and at the moment it absolutely
dominates
in fact it does so to the point that it
has spilled out of just
being the thing that draws attention to
a youtube channel
and has become the trade of small trendy
restaurants who have taken to creating
absurd dishes that exist for the sole
purpose of being photographically
unusual
and drawing the attention of social
media personalities
hell at vidcon 2019 this was the bedrock
theme of the entire
instagram creator lounge and while we're
talking about negative outcomes i
suppose now is as good a time as any to
discuss the elephant in the room
channels like blossom so yummy and
5-minute crafts
something about them should be familiar
to anyone aware of the frozen elsa
spider-man trend of horrifying cg videos
that consumed
children's entertainment on youtube a
couple years back
these blanket food slash craft channels
utilize a similar format with each video
consisting of an anthology of shorter
segments
that are often recycled across several
videos individual segments are churned
out by what is effectively a warehouse
of video teams
so for example this blossom video 12
creative ways to use coca-cola life
hacks by blossom
only has around 5 minutes of kohler
related hacks
followed by 9 minutes of hacks recycled
from other videos to pad out the runtime
though the cola hacks at least three are
just
used cola as a marinade and they use
cola to get gum out of hair
twice and you just put laundry detergent
into coke
and filled a nail hole with
soap what are you
that's that's not a hack you didn't i'm
sorry i got sucked in there
ann reardon the owner and host of how to
cook that and her husband dave have done
some great
investigative reporting into the
business structure of these channels
i've included the links below in the
description as per
our model these channels rely heavily on
the spectacle of their recipes though
rather than attempting to create
something
comically elaborate they aim for
spectacularly simple executions
making complex time-consuming or tricky
recipes almost
unbelievably simple and they do that by
just outright lying like using cola as
glass cleaner
which you know nothing quite cleans
glass like sugary amber liquid
or using it as a stain remover because
coke is famous for not staining clothing
and sure why not just stick a pencil let
into your locks
now you're just using chalk
as stain remover what are you even
sorry it happened again it's probably
worth mentioning that informational
value should really be
perceived informational value see it's
not about
being a recipe that you can follow along
with and produce similar results
it's about looking like a recipe that
you can follow
the trick is that most viewers won't try
to make the vast majority of what they
watch and this goes just as much
for a 200 year old wedding cake recipe
that takes a week to assemble
or a 5-minute omelet this is then doubly
true for things that are
odd and impractical like the long egg
and it turns out that you can crank out
a lot of videos extremely fast if you're
willing to just
lie content farms are able to publish
thousands of videos every month and even
for well-established creators that's a
really really difficult format to
compete with
this is a tremendous amount of effort
because you're taking all of the normal
complication of video production
and adding in perishables and time
limits and there's a lot of mistakes you
can make that mean
starting over it's an expensive type of
video to make
and to bring this full circle that
expense
is going to dictate to some degree or
another what kinds of videos get made
by whom now despite everything i've said
despite the way things
structurally bias towards rewarding
well-funded well-equipped corporate
teams
despite the fact that making a cooking
channel is a bad idea and you shouldn't
do it
i am glad that so many people ignore
that advice and do it anyway because the
beauty of youtube
is that there is still room for someone
who is scrappy and clever
to share their own voice with the rest
of the world
i i love this one and i think everyone
should try it
i really do hope you give this a try
soon so i hope you can give it a try
and that's shortbread chocolate chip
cookies if you make them let me know
what you think in the comments
and as always thanks for watching
i wanted to make this video as a way of
interrogating my own relationship to the
media that i consume
i enjoy the spectacle of food
entertainment and in particular i
like seeing the absurd and the indulgent
i want to see the world's largest papaya
or reasonably authentic
2000 year old recipes or a giant
hamburger that is actually made of ice
cream cake
spectacle sells and make no mistake i am
buying
but also i am aware that there is a view
of the world and an
attitude towards food and a philosophy
of food
that is carried with that it is not
inherently good or bad but
neither is it value neutral implicit in
each is a statement about what is good
in the world and what the world
should be like and yeah that can be
prescriptive and constraining but it can
also be enriching
expanding our tastes and appreciation of
culture and sensation
because that's when i like cooking the
most when it's not just about
food but a celebration of what food
represents now if you'll excuse me
i got some dishes to do
[Music]
do
also a pizza pop is just a tiny calzone